hey everyone so I'm so excited because
the purge 2 trailer just came out Inaki
the first one I was a little
disappointed in and so I'm just really
excited to see if it actually looks like
it could be a scary movie by the way
happy Valentine's Day everyone who's
watching this here we go I got Enzo
anxious doesn't sound anxious happening
they seemed awful surprised like they
didn't know that was gonna happen of
course they don't even happen we think
you want to do
dude looks like they were jamming
through Miley Cyrus anima bustling oh my
gosh look at the Metro bus okay that
actually looks really freaky I really
want to see that just not alone in the
movie theater No thank you by the way go
subscribe to my channel subscribe to
this channel because the boys are
awesome everything is awesome he helped
me out so much with my new short film go
check it out on my channel Ryan has a
promo on this one so check that out as
well cuz it's super funny and it's just
like a bunch of scenes that we couldn't
use but I really want to do cuz they're
hilarious I hope you enjoyed it I
enjoyed it I'm really excited about this
movie it looks intense peace out